thank you
on animal ER the team of Houston's top
veterinarians treat a white tiger in
crisis
for the first time
but during their daring surgery I got a
little bleeding this life-threatening
complication set in the Tiger's
oxygenation status started to go down
and a special companion for an ailing
child they fell in love instantly it
requires urgent intervention this is the
kind of case that can go south very
quickly while a beloved lab needs a
delicate surgery to savor life it's not
getting better
if we don't do something it's animal
medicine
at a whole new level there's almost
nothing we can't do at Gulf Coast
thank you
the staff is going to attempt a first at
Gulf Coast today as they get ready to
meet a special new patient
a six-year-old white Bengal tiger named
Nia
he's a rescue who lives five hours away
at The Pride Rock Wildlife Refuge
over the last few months she's been
hemorrhaging during her menstrual cycle
Nia has never given birth to a litter
her owner called Dr Brian Beal this
tiger is having reproductive problems
basically having discharges and
occasionally mild infections and what
we're going to try to do is get that
uterus out of there they're going to
have to perform an ovario hysterectomy
to remove the uterus and ovaries
but there's a Twist Gulf Coast is not
equipped to house the tiger overnight
surgery must take place quickly enough
that she can go home the same day that
table's on Wheels so we can just wheel
it out right oh yeah but being that this
guy is so
we're just trying to clear the way to
make it easiest for us to come into the
or move out of the or it's a complex
procedure the animal weighs 350 pounds
Dr Beale assembles two interns two
additional surgeons and a team of
Veterinary techs as well as exotic
animal expert Danielle Inman to assist
hey Gary
so we're all here to give you some help
we're glad to be here how was the ride
it's not been a uh one of our better
moments but uh she worked up how she
kind of take a peek at her uh
yeah all right they're also attempting
something brand new to use a minimally
invasive technique a hysterectomy like
this has rarely been attempted on a
tiger before
bars don't look
as to be when she's behind them and
she's growling at you
it really made her presence known and it
got all of our attention
Nia is restless and
Dr Caleb Hudson has the most experience
with tiger surgery on this team
big cats are they're very powerful
creatures and even if they're even if
they're tame and they're used to you you
know it can be unsafe we won't really be
able to to get close to it and do much
of an exam on it until it's it's heavily
sedated
[Applause]
by myself sure
one of Nia's handlers attempts to calm
her
while a zoo veterinarian gets ready to
administer a cocktail of sedatives
powerful enough to temporarily knock out
a 350 pound tiger it's been nice knowing
you Joe when I hear big cat surgery
there's a couple things that come into
my mind and one is keeping the cat
asleep so we've brought in an exotic
animal specialist to handle the
anesthetic and also the pain management
of this big cat
either on that side or she's going to
need to be on this side
it's a back open
all right
knee is in an agitated State they do not
want her to attack the cage and injure
herself or the people around her
baby
[Music]
I'm Miss Sandoval with Harley yeah come
to the bed we're ready for you
[Music]
Harley is a newly adopted puppy with a
serious elbow fracture Harley was
running alongside my husband and she
went to cut in front of him as they were
running and her leg got caught in
between his and they tumbled down and
she fell and broke her elbow
the family got Harley to be a companion
for their daughter
suffers from a rare genetic disorder
our daughter has been in and out of the
hospital her whole life
Sawyer has been asking for a puppy for
months
we made her a promise that when she was
healthy enough to have a puppy that we
would let her get one
we took her to the shelter and they fell
in love instantly we went for Sawyer to
have as normal life as possible
having a puppy is all part of that
process
so our biggest concern for Harley is
that she's unable to run and play like a
normal dog and that's just something I
don't want for her
Dr Wayne Whitney an orthopedic surgeon
at Gulf Coast is on the case
Brittany nice to meet you why don't you
come over
so here's what we're seeing do you see
that yeah
okay that concerns me it's fractured
through this part but it hasn't
fractured through the rest of the bone
it's it's almost like um piece of wood
that you split almost all the way I'm
hoping that we can get to this before it
becomes a full-blown fracture so that's
the goal
um I would
you know I'd say let's just go ahead and
do it this is the kind of case that I
worry about just walking around on the
hospital floor I know you know this
could go south very quickly
you will have to prepare for
ever the worst right I'm I'm sorry
you're going to go through this but I'm
I'm glad that we're getting a chance to
get it before it becomes a much more
serious and expensive problem I agree
completely and I mean we brought the dog
specifically for our daughters and she
loves her seriously thank you so much
Harley is
more than just a pet she got this dog
for her child that you know has has
special needs and as a father I feel
very responsible to help every way I can
you're not just treating a pet you're
treating the whole family Harley's
fracture could get worse at any moment
Dr Whitney chooses to operate
immediately
so our goal is to go in with a scope and
then we can put a clamp across it to
compress the fracture arthroscopically
and then put a lag screw across and then
prevent it from becoming a disaster
the first step in the surgery is to find
exactly where the fracture is okay Dr
Whitney will use an arthroscope to
examine inside Harley's elbow all right
can you see that crack right across
there yes
all right so there's the fracture
identified the fracture in his scope now
Dr Whitney must drill exactly into the
right place to compress it if he is off
by even a few millimeters the bone will
heal incorrectly leaving Harley disabled
all right so you on your fracture
all right
there you go
all right let's do it
a bird is in critical condition it's
having difficulty breathing
Dr Natalie Antonov prepares for
emergency surgery spirit is a 16 year
old cockatiel who has a mass growing in
her mouth covering up the opening to her
trachea and that's why she can't breathe
hi baby I know it's awful there's a very
good possibility that we're not going to
be able to get this mask off but at this
point in time with the way that she
looks today I feel like if we didn't do
this procedure she would have less than
24 hours to live okay
Dr Antonov gives Spirit a sedative first
she must evaluate the mass that is
rapidly growing and choking the 16 year
old pet
we're going to do sort of the bird
equivalent of a tracheotomy and then
we're going to open up her mouth look
and see what we see in there if we think
we can get any of this off and give her
Comfort we're going to go ahead and
remove it and do our best but if we
can't remove any of it without making
her worse then we're not going to do
anything
[Music]
where is she breathing yes
okay so what they're doing is putting a
monitor her on and at the same time I am
plucking the feathers and preparing her
for surgery
normally I would be using a drape for
this a sterile drape but she's a tiny
little bird and time is kind of of the
essence with her
tiny little window
making my incision
it's a pretty small incision into the
skin if I go through the muscle until I
get to the body wall
okay and this is the tricky part popping
in
there we go and I'll take that tube
so this is the airway tube so this is
the equivalent of like a tracheotomy and
we're going to test this
to see if it expands
ready
good we're in okay
[Music]
so now I'm just sutureing it in place
Dr Antonov finishes suturing the
incision and has to work fast
Spirits Advanced age and the sedation
make even a tracheotomy risky before Dr
Antonov can examine the mass and Spirits
throat the cockatiel takes a turn for
the worse
spirit's heart has stopped beating
let's get some
epic as they would with a human patient
they try to kick-start spirit's heart
with a shot of epinephrine
okay hang on
now we don't worry so much about being
sterile as we do about getting
everything into her
this is delicate CR
ime
Dr Antonov is attempting to revive
spirit
[Music]
a cockatiel with a mass growing around
her throat
moments ago her heart stopped beating
during an emergency Airway surgery
where's that fluid with dextrose I'd
like to get a little bit of dextroge
into her just to drop all right let me
check and see if we've got anything here
it's good that we've got at least we got
the airway
because I don't think
we got something
really erratic let's give it another
round let's get more epi
[Music]
so nothing
oh we're gonna stop we're gonna stop
I'm sorry sweetheart
once we had done three rounds of CPR we
I went ahead and said let me just look
in her mouth because we really didn't
get the chance to look in her mouth
while she was still alive oh you know
what the team realizes it was a losing
battle all along the mass and spirit's
throat was already past the point of any
treatment you see that it's on her
trachea
it's huge and it's attached really
really firmly
I there's no taking that out so I feel
like even if we could take the mouse off
part of it today it's going to come
right back and we're going to be right
back in this exact same situation oh
poor baby this is probably the worst
I've seen
I have to call Mr medley and let him
know the news and he he knew
fully going into this what the odds were
for her to pull through hey it's Dr
Antonoff
um I don't have good news for you about
Spirit
unfortunately if she did not make it
through the procedure
never gets easier to make those calls
she felt no pain she wasn't suffering
I'm I'm so so sorry
it's hard it never gets easier if it did
I think I'd have to stop being a
veterinarian
thank you
[Music]
oh and play with me Allen we're allowed
to encourage all of the naughty behavior
that we don't encourage in our own
animals
exactly
Nia a six-year-old white Bengal tiger is
at Gulf Coast to have her uterus removed
to stop her chronic bleeding it will be
a groundbreaking surgery
after just getting her out of her cage
and into the hospital is a challenge
oh
that was good
so what we did in this case is her
keeper was distracting her with some
good little rump scratches and then Dr
Joe gave the injection so now what
should happen is she should get very
sleepy pretty quickly here and then at
that point she'll be you know a lot
safer and we'll get her downstairs to
begin prepping
[Music]
are you sleepy
a little bit we're gonna give her like
to at least 10 more minutes
I wouldn't mind if she had more I don't
think anybody would
it's not always easy to tell what plane
of anesthesia patient's at they can act
like they're asleep but certainly we see
it in dogs and cats where they seem like
they're asleep but when we stimulate
them they pop right back up and want to
bite us
there's no way to move Nia without
lifting her onto a gurney and time is
limited they must get her under a more
powerful general anesthetic before the
temporary sedation wears off
so we're gonna move her from her crate
onto the gurney so that we can get her
downstairs to the prep room and surgical
Suite
up as much as we can
one two three
let's go
[Music]
we're taking the tiger out of the cage
we're putting her onto the gurney and
then we're transporting her into the
elevator and down the elevator to the
hospital and during that time she's just
laying there on the gurney asleep
so I'd say there's definitely a little
bit of apprehension
we were nervous for a variety of reasons
Asia don't always mix well
and so we've really got to hurry things
along
it was a surreal experience to see a
tiger come down our hallway
my technician skills kind of went into
high gear so I was really focused on
that but at the same time I kept
thinking this is an amazing creature
the biggest challenge with treating a
tiger is just her sheer size
which is a massive animal and so just
having enough manpower to lift her is is
a unique situation
we ready everyone's ready
leading the Gulf Coast team for Nia's
procedure is one of the youngest
surgeons on the staff Dr Caleb Hudson
the first surgery that I participated in
was a spay on a cat
I was 16 years old I just got my
driver's license from that time on
surgery was very fascinating to me I
trained at the University of Florida
there's a lot of big cats in Florida so
I have a little bit of experience into
surgery on Tigers but nothing minimally
invasive so to have the the chance to do
you know a laparoscopic surgery on a
tiger is is pretty exciting
doctors Hudson and Beale are going to
try a procedure that has rarely been
done on a tiger before
they will use small incisions and a
lighted camera called a laparoscope to
help them remove the uterus
the recovery time for this procedure is
far less than with open surgery what
we're doing is we're making an incision
into the abdomen and we're going to put
a port and we'll allow us to put a scope
into the abdomen
the goal is to get Nia in and out of
surgery and able to travel home as fast
as possible can we start insufflation
under general anesthesia they're limited
to approximately three hours start to
finish to be able to see inside the
abdomen for a minimally invasive surgery
you have to distend the abdominal cavity
with carbon dioxide gas and that
distension puts pressure on the
diaphragm which tends to collapse the
lungs down so you've got to work very
very quickly so now we should be able to
put the scope in and have a look around
[Music]
here it comes
oh yeah yeah so we're moving forward in
the abdomen looking at part of the
stomach and the spleen
as we move back and around you can see
oh there's a part of the
suspensory ligament of the uterus and
the ovary and then we're gonna just
figure out where we're gonna establish
our instrument portal which
we're going to want to be a lot too far
away
team will use three small incisions one
for the laparoscope to illuminate knee
as organs and the other two for the
surgical instruments to remove the
uterus this case is more challenging
than most of the cases of laparoscopic
surgery and tigers that have been done
before
can you show me now where it's pointing
to make sure I'm not going to stab into
the school for whatever reason no one's
no one's chosen to use laparoscopic
surgery to operate on a tiger that has a
uterine problem before
so it's definitely more difficult
there it is
that's beautiful that's beautiful
so we're progressively cauterizing the
blood vessels and resecting the tissue a
lot of vessels there but so far this is
bloodless yes it's going great
okay let's look at the uterus now Ryan
try to see how much of the uterus we can
actually see just as doctors Hudson and
Beale get to the uterus to remove it
they discover a problem on one side of
the uterus they were not expecting
[Music]
sir uterus is super large on this side
this uterus was many many times normal
size let's get we got a little bleeding
it turned out that the uterus was very
abnormal she had a condition that we
call a pyometra which is an infection
which makes the tissue unhealthy it
makes it break more easily it makes it
bleed more easily
we were not anticipating that
[Music]
are you Duchess is a nine-year-old Lab
mix who is suffering from a lump in her
head and a persistent discharge from her
left eye well my concern is we know
she's not feeling well and her skull is
caving in
there's a concern that what is going on
inside of her head is cancer she's a
part of the family
so we're hoping for the best and that is
not
Dr Heidi hottinger a soft tissue
specialist orders an MRI and conducts a
physical exam can you look at me baby
girl there we go so this little lady has
a condition going on in her middle ear
could be cancer
but more likely is a benign process
called a cholesteatoma
it erodes through bone it actually is
invading into her brain compressing her
brain so she has a lot of muscle loss
right here rounded over here caved in
here and then also her eye is sunken and
she's not producing tear enough tear
either so she's got an ulcer on her eye
surgery appears to be the only option
for Duchess hi Mr Sparks hello I'm Dr
Heidi hottinger nice to meet you have a
seat we're going to talk about a few
things
so I can't give you a guarantee yet that
this is not tumor right I wish I could
but she does fit a lot of the picture of
a dog that has this condition which is
called a cholesteatoma here's what we
know about them is that if we can go in
and get a lot of that waxy material out
we can kind of get a lot of this under
control things we have to keep in mind
though is that some of the nerve damage
that is present
may not go away
so
the biggest thing I do have a concern
about is the eye
there is the option of saying wow if all
of this is to make her feel better if
she has an eye that's always ulcerated
and painful maybe she would be better
without that eye exactly let me show you
a few things on her MRI too so you kind
of know what we're doing
so here we have this little bit of black
here we have this great big area of kind
of white stuff and look at her brain on
this side notice how it's touching her
brain I do
see we really don't know if it's tumor
David in there we do so here's what we
would do when I go in
if it's tumor
versus this cholesteatoma they look
completely different they have a
completely different texture I'll know
if you want some time to think through
all of this
the truth
heard that yes give her a good quality
for a while that's kind of why my wife
and myself have decided to do great
we'll get that all set up and then I'll
give you a call after a surgery already
okay thank you so much I will take good
care of your girl I know with Duchess
it's only going downhill from here it's
not getting better if we don't do
something
all right baby go ahead I see you later
dude
you're a good girl
Dr Whitney is operating on an elbow
fracture on Harley a therapy puppy and
the Beloved playful companion to a
two-year-old girl named Sawyer Dr
Whitney must insert a tiny screw to
compress the fracture in exactly the
right place all right
there you go
if he is even millimeters off the bone
will not heal correctly
Sawyer could lose her playmate
all right let's do it
[Music]
okay now we're going to screw the head
of the screw in as Dr Whitney positions
the screw he watches the fracture in the
scope to see if it compresses correctly
[Music]
perfect
all right we're done
it's beautiful I can be happy with that
it's gonna feel very good about it I
don't want to jinx this but it was
exactly what we thought so we went ahead
and compressed it back down and that
that headless compression screw that we
put in
and hold it there and should allow it to
heal and this stuff should do great
foreign
[Music]
the next day Harley's family returns to
pick her up
yeah no Harley doesn't need a stroller
no Harley's gonna walk because we got
her leg fixed hi guys hey how are you
thank you for your patience how are you
great hi hi
Harley are you gonna see her
as a father it was definitely
emotionally gratifying she feels all
better that dog's gonna do great and be
there to support that little girl for a
long time you know that's probably the
part of this case that feels the best
tell Dr Whitney thank you
you're very welcome
[Music]
it will take a few weeks to determine if
Harley's elbow heals correctly and she
can go back to being the rambunctious
puppy Sawyer needs
Nia a white Bengal tiger has been in
surgery for 90 minutes when things take
an unexpected turn
we were expecting a uterus that was
going to be pretty small maybe slightly
bigger than normal size this uterus was
many many times normal sized she had a
condition that we call a pyometra which
is an infection we got a little bleeding
try and try to focus on this area right
up here to see if we're getting any
Hemorrhage from right in here
we were not anticipating that we're not
gonna be able to do anything about that
there's too many vessels so we're just
gonna have to get it out they're hoping
to be as minimally invasive as possible
but the Tiger has a serious infection
and internal bleeding
and now a new and troubling problem
suddenly emerges for Nia one of one of
her Vital Signs starts falling her blood
oxygen level
uh 77 let's see
75. did it just suddenly decline or has
it been like them for a while we started
to have a few anesthetic issues this
lack of oxygen to the brain is called
hypoxemia a condition that mountain
climbers get when they collapse in high
altitudes and they can die if their
levels don't stabilize the Tiger's
oxygenation status started to go down
and so we look for that value to be
somewhere above 95 percent and when it
starts to drop lower and lower into the
low 90s or the 80s or the 70s you start
to worry about getting brain damage
potentially
[Music]
I started to get pretty nervous because
you know you don't have a lot of time
left at this point but also you know
you're not really that close to being
done with the surgery
the nail biter you become more and more
and more nervous I became more and more
and more nervous you know just watching
those vitals change in a negative way it
became more and more critical that we
finish this and we finish it quickly and
we were only halfway done so it wasn't
like we could just stop and close and
say well we'll fix it tomorrow we had to
continue on to make matters worse Nia's
uterus is too swollen to remove it
through any of the small laparoscopy
holes we're trying to make the decision
where to go and open open her up and
just get it knocked out real quick
you could probably just get our uterus
out of this right yeah yeah let's let's
go ahead and make it I think we need to
get my guess is that we had about 45
minutes to an hour from when we started
opening uh but the longer you get more
chance there is that she may not wake up
okay from the anesthesia it's just go in
and open this and get the last piece out
we can't lose this tiger under
anesthesia and if they have to start
waking her up we have to be done with
the surgery before they wake her up okay
let's go can we surgery lights on please
okay
blood oxygen level falling and the time
they can keep Nia under anesthesia
running out Dr Hudson attempts to
enlarge the small portals created for
Nia's surgery to pull out the rest of
her infected uterus immediately you know
I started to get pretty nervous we need
to open this and move forward very
quickly
[Music]
there we go
all right
yeah good it's coming up okay great
color looks much better yeah it's
actually very good that we went in and
got this out I don't think she would
have uh lasted long with a plus filled
uterus like we saw here
[Music]
all right let's have some are we gonna
have some flush
we weren't able to do the whole surgery
as minimally invasively as we'd hoped
but based on the size of the uterus that
we found in there we were able to do it
as minimally invasively as you can with
the uterus of that size the surgical
task is done and Nia's vitals are
getting better but Dr Hudson knows that
Nia isn't out of the woods yet
damaging complications from being under
anesthesia this long are still a big
concern looking up at the screen and
seeing that the numbers are lower than
you expect them to be I start to get
very nervous because I start to wonder
will we be able to get her back is she
going to wake up from this surgery or
not I didn't know what was going to
happen
[Music]
Dr hottinger's team prepares Duchess a
nine-year-old Lab mix for surgery
it's pretty prominent with all the hair
clipped off
yeah
yeah it's okay it'll go back into look
all pretty again
Dr hottinger will remove duchess's
ulcerated left eye and some of her ear
canal before the most critical part of
the surgery
cutting deep into duchess's ear canal
and determining whether the lumpy
substance near her brain is cancerous
Duck Butt you can't be 100 sure until
you go in there
this could be tumor and if it is the
whole game plan changes
[Music]
so right now we're dissecting around the
ear canal and then that will get us down
where all of this debris has accumulated
Dr hottinger has to carefully remove a
growth from the left side of duchess's
head
a nine-year-old Lab mix who came in with
a lump on her head and an ulcerated eye
only open surgery will determine whether
the lump is cancerous or not
this is great it's not a camera
so what I found when I opened up was
exactly what I was hoping for was this
material that is consistent with a
cholecyatoma and basically it looks like
soft candle wax and you just scoop it
out lots of it this is good
Dr hottinger has ruled out cancer but
she still needs to remove more of the
waxy substance around the brain
here's where we're kind of getting into
the brain okay so if anybody comes to
the door no okay
I couldn't be distracted when I was
working up in a very deep dark hole
around her brain I needed to not tremble
move Look Away when someone talked with
me no I I needed to have it all about
duchess
[Music]
thank you
all right
you know makes for a good day and you
feel like you made a difference
especially for a sweet little lady like
this
[Music]
hi it's Dr hottinger calling
everything went very well no cancer it's
like hip hip hooray you guys can
celebrate tonight okay thank you bye-bye
[Music]
here at Gulf Coast we provide the care
for our staff dogs
we actually have a running waiting list
for employee dogs we can fit them in
and once it's their turn
you bring them in
everything went great
best thing of all is when you get those
huge heartfelt hugs
but it's sweetie pie it just makes it
all worthwhile
she's good he's good
Nia the Tiger has just finished a
dramatic surgery that removed her
infected uterus
one two three however a full half hour
afterwards Nia is still out
the Gulf Coast team led by Dr Beale and
Dr Hudson fears she could be suffering
from the adverse effects of prolonged
anesthesia as shown by one of Nia's
vital signs that they're watching
the anesthesiologists were periodically
monitoring the electrolyte values and
what they were finding was a trend where
the potassium was going up every time
they measured it
make sure she has plenty of water to
drink
potassium is mildly elevated that's not
a big problem for the body but if the
potassium starts to get very very high
it can actually result in death I mean
it can be fatal
oh there we go
breathe in faster now so when her oxygen
went back up to normal and she was
breathing on her own that's a good sign
but then I still had to worry about did
that low oxygen tension in her blood do
anything to damage her her brain
[Music]
thank you
when a tiger's waking up from anesthesia
we're watching for some indicators that
she's waking up okay all right that her
that her mental status is okay at six
years old Nia is in the prime of Life
under normal conditions she could live
another 10 to 12 years but big cats
don't always metabolize anesthesia so we
want her to to just be
[Music]
we'd like her to be lifting her head and
have a little more wherewithal before we
send her home
get her in the trailer gear out of the
sun if you'd love to have a sunburned
chummy
[Applause]
every minute that passes with Nia
unconscious creates more concern about
her full recovery what we want to see is
that she starts trying to move she's
kind of making an attempt to write
herself to get into a more normal
position for a tiger to to to sit or lay
come on
Leah
[Music]
come on girl you know as I'm looking at
her and she's she's taking much longer
than I want her to to wake up
she's been given the antidotes for the
drugs the sedation that we gave and so
she should be there with us but she's
she's not she's still sedate and so it's
scary
[Music]
less than 24 hours after ear and eye
surgery near her brain Duchess is ready
to reunite with her owner
there's a girl number hair is Cliff
she says we're on this side she's like I
hear your voice
there we go hello
hey I heard you was a good girl
I don't think he was a good girl she is
such a wonderful girl we love her
I'm glad to see Duchess back I think
that everything that we had done here
is going to make her happier dog
you know we got Duchess from a no-kill
pet shelter and we've had her we've had
Dutch's eight years
you know it's we're her no kill family
oh they
is part of my job
the best part of the job that never
stopped I know
when you get that hug it means the world
thanks bye
[Music]
come here Harley
two-year-old Sawyer Sandoval's parents
wanted to give her a puppy to help her
cope with the stress of her rare genetic
disorder and now five weeks after Dr
Whitney's precise surgery sealing a
stress fracture on her elbow Harley is
living up to her promise of being an
active companion to Sawyer
we are thrilled that Harley is doing so
well so iron Harley just love to play
they're up and down the stage hairs all
the time come here Harley hold on we're
so relieved that she's gonna be able to
enjoy her puppy and they're going to
have a wonderful life together
open your eyes girl
[Music]
Nia the white Bengal tiger who had an
emergency hysterectomy has still not
come out of anesthesia her surgical team
is concerned about possible brain damage
and won't leave her side until she wakes
up
under anesthesia you know there's really
no movements I mean the body is
relatively paralyzed
you need to be watching for the subtle
indicators that she's waking up okay
that we didn't cause any harm by
anesthetizing her
come on
Nia
come on girl
come on baby
let's go
come here
come on baby
what's going on baby
come on girl
there we go
yeah she finally like opened her eyes
and
she's looking at Danielle now she's
waking up to Danielle yeah she's about
to lift her head she wants to
come on girl
come on get him come on good girl
there she goes yeah
here we go
that's when I started to relax that's
when I started to breathe aside relief
and say this is a normal recovery I mean
it just looks like a large version of a
domestic cat waking up from anesthesia
I think she's gonna be fine being able
to work on a tiger it was it was a very
happy experience for me
faced with the challenges we were faced
with today we we really shined you know
everyone did a fantastic job came
together that made me happy
thank you thank you this surgery was a
big surgery for us it built a lot of
morale and it showed people at our
hospital that they could do things that
they didn't know that they could do
Gary hey it's Dr Beal how did Naya do on
the on the trailer ride home
uh after we got her out of the trailer
here
[Music]
a big hug for me okay
really that tiger
made me think that there's almost
nothing we can't do at Gulf Coast now
[Music]